i did want to ask you about what it was
like for you when the show came
to a close because you have a huge fan
base a lot of people love
victorious but you're an actor on a show
and there's only so much that's in
your control so when you're still that
young and that early on in your career
what was it like kind of balancing fan
expectations and also
you know the situation that you were in
in terms of a show not being in your
control
yeah it definitely was not in my control
at all i
i had no decision making um power there
whatsoever
um and to be honest i i thought that the
show was for sure going another season
like there was no doubt in my mind we
were gonna go another season
um so i was honestly just as shocked as
everyone else
um but i think at the end of the day you
know of course i would i would
have loved for our show to have like an
epic finale because i think it
did deserve that um and i think it would
have been so epic and really really fun
but you know life goes on and i'm just
so grateful that
so many people did love the show and to
this day still watch the show
um and i think as an actor you know you
also get to a certain point where you're
you know i was growing up i was maturing
i was evolving and
um i think i was 20 at that point so i
was also ready to
branch out and try new things and take
on some more mature roles and
um i was exploring music a little bit
more at that time and
um so i think all of us to be honest
we're ready in our own ways to to move
on and try our
other things but i think i think we all
felt that we would have loved like a
more like final um finale
uh but you know it is all good and and
it's a great show and people love it and
i'm very proud of it